roughly 1600 miles northeast of uvalde
another community in buffalo new york is
grieving from a recent mass shooting
mourners gathered yesterday to honor a
retired police lieutenant killed trying
to stop the gunman it was one of two
funerals yesterday for the victims of
the racist attack that killed 10 black
people our national correspondent jerica
duncan is in buffalo near the site of
the shooting good morning jerica
good morning to you michelle you know
there are growing memorials at each
corner here surrounding this tops it is
clear that this community will not
forget about these 10 lives lost and
yesterday we did have the pleasure and
the honor of attending the funeral
service for aaron salter jr he is
credited with warning shoppers to run he
also fired at the gunman and simply put
the buffalo police commissioner said he
saved lives
[Music]
inside this church near buffalo
grief was everywhere
this time for 55 year old aaron salter
jr
former buffalo deputy commissioner
kimberly beatty
this is tough
aaron was a good man
a good person
and we all deserve better
his casket was draped in an american
flag a fitting tribute to the husband
father of three and retired buffalo
police officer salter was on duty as a
security guard at tops when he became
one of the 10 black people gunned down
by an 18 year old who law enforcement
officials say was motivated by hate
aaron bravely fought evil that day
his life inspired many he gave all that
he had for all that he believed in
protecting and saving lives
after the service it was back to serving
the community for local volunteers
right now i could see a lot of hurt
wednesday rapper and philanthropists
trade the truth alongside social justice
organization until freedom joined in
he came to buffalo with an 18-wheeler
full of food and toiletries filling a
void left behind from the now closed
neighborhood tops grocery store
while planning this trip he learned of
tuesday's massacre at the elementary
school in texas trey's home state
these are babies you know like i have
kids
that age and younger i couldn't even
imagine what type of pain that is and
it's that pain that drives him to
tragedy after tragedy this morning he's
off to uvalde i got to be there for them
just as well i'm going to meet with the
families
reach out to the mayor
see what assistance they need let them
know that houston
definitely behind them and other places
are behind them
a lot of people here in buffalo
expressing their concerns for what
happened in texas and as it pertains to
this mass shooting the funerals will be
held friday and saturday gail
i'm so glad that you're there jericho
you know that story seems so long ago
but actually it really isn't the story
didn't happen weeks ago
so i think it's an important reminder
you know how people say what we need in
this country is a good guy with a gun
that man was a good guy with a gun and
lost his life trying to help and save
others
save saved a lot of lives but like you
said he's he's not with us anymore yeah
very tragic
it's tough i know jericho was on a
flight to cover that
that funeral when all of this happened
broke it's it's just it
there are no words there are no words
and i feel for tony he has children the
age of those children you know when you
cover these things and you have people
in your lives like that it really
impacts you it affects everyone i mean
the entire country is mourning with them
you think of people that have gone
through this before
it's a i hate saying a club but it's a
group of people no one wants to be a
part of these two communities tied
together with others forever forever in
a way they don't yeah what we all know
is whether you have children or you
don't have children everybody knows when
your child goes to school they're not
supposed to come home in a body bag no
they're not and part of the problem too
is not only did your child die but your
head
goes nuts when you think about how they
died and that's why this is so very
painful for all of us
with a with a beating heart